we're only 15 days away from the draft
we have seen some unexpected things
happen over the last month or so some
trades that maybe turned the nfl upside
down antonio brown to the raiders otto
beckham jr to the browns and former
jaguars and raiders coach jack del rio
threw something out there the other day
that provides a door number three to the
russell wilson situation in seattle
because we had assumed the options were
one
you sign into a long-term deal before
his deadline of april 15. two if you
don't he's going to go year to year
under the franchise tag at least into
2020 maybe beyond but now there's number
three and jack del rio appearing on nfl
network said don't be surprised
if before it's all said and done when we
line up for the season next year meaning
this year if russell wilson isn't
quarterbacking somewhere else and the
seahawks haven't gone and gotten a
quarterback they think for the future i
was stunned by that one because i don't
think jack del rio is going to go on tv
and say that if he hasn't heard it from
somebody he trusts and there must be
something out there something that's
getting started i think back to the
rumors that were being mongered by colin
coward about a trade to the giants
because russell wilson's wife sierra
doesn't like living in seattle and she
wants to be in more of a media capital
because she's got a singing career i
look i this thing
gradually slowly but almost inevitably
is taking on a life of its own and i i
take what del rio said seriously and i'm
going to start paying attention now to
whether or not that becomes a thing the
possibility of the seahawks trading
russell wilson instead of making him the
highest paid player in the nfl or
playing that kirk cousins franchise tag
dance well i mean no question am i
paying attention to this from now first
of all yes ex-nfl coaches you know they
just don't make these kind of statements
unless they've been told this by
somebody so
again jack del rio's not trying to break
into the nfl breaking news business uh i
think this is something that he has
heard and let me just say let's connect
the dots a little bit right who was jack
del rio's defensive coordinator when he
was with the oakland raiders
huh
ken norton jr um where did he come from
seattle where is he now i believe he's
back in seattle am i correct with that i
did i should have looked that up before
i started saying that before but here's
the thing
del rio fired him too so i don't know
whether ken norton's returning del rio's
call maybe they get along well maybe
they get along you're right but all i
know is there's probably somebody he
knows up on that staff that's all i'm
trying to kind of make the point of that
at least that's where my brain goes at
first but there seems to be a lot of
weird things about this russell wilson
seattle seahawk thing first off just
from the base level of football russell
wilson we know is awesome but also the
seattle seahawks are the type of team uh
that i've always looked at and we've
kind of dabbled in this conversation
where
last few weeks i've always said who's
gonna be the first team that has the
guts to move on from a big time
franchise quarterback and say okay we're
going to restart at square one with a
young quarterback and build our team
around
depth and great players and have a
quarterback on the rookie
salary cap option still and that's how
the seattle seahawks dynasty was built
or not dynasty but their great playoff
run i mean russell wilson was on a
rookie quarterback contract uh he was a
third round pick and they had an
unbelievable team deep defensive line
off awesome offensive line running backs
corners they had it all so i from that
aspect i do look at seattle as one of
the teams going they're probably going
huh we won that way once could we do it
again but then you mentioned mike i mean
the rumors about the new york giants uh
sierra not being happy and wants to go
to a big market
stuff like that in my experience
that just doesn't just come out of thin
air usually there's been some talk or
some type of conversation out of the
fact of the weird contract talk dynamics
uh and all of that added into it as well
so yeah to me on like a topical level uh
it looks like both sides maybe are not
afraid to make a move here but i don't
know that it's you know purely
speculative at this point
when russell wilson was on the tonight
show with jimmy fallon last month and we
focused on the question from fallon
about possibly being the highest paid
player in the nfl the answer by wilson
there's a great potential for that that
same interview also included a question
for wilson about the rumors of being
traded giants and he said i don't think
the seahawks are going to let me go well
if they change their mind then
there's 31 different franchises out
there that to some degree or another may
be interested in russell wilson now the
teams that have young ascending
franchise quarterbacks aren't going to
give it a second thought like the chiefs
with patrick mahomes and the browns with
baker mayfield but chris you look around
the landscape of the nfl right now are
there teams to jump out to you and let's
start with the giants would it make
sense for the giants to make a play
would you give up picks number six and
17 in round one
for russell wilson right now if you were
the giants uh ooh
pick six and seventeen for russell
wilson right now oh i don't know if i
could do both uh yeah i would certainly
think about it let's just say that and i
didn't expect you to ask me that
question but um six and 17 for a team
like the new york giants i think that's
probably a little too rich with all the
holes they have added to the fact that
you're going to have to pay him to be
one of the highest paid quarterbacks in
the history of football so i would say
no that's maybe a little too much but
maybe one of those picks packaged with
something else uh then i would think
about it if i'm the new york giants the
other thing you got to take into play
here and especially if this happened
between now and the draft is okay if
they do that what are the giants gonna
do they just gonna you know have russell
wilson and eli manning together on the
same team and what eli is just gonna be
the most expensive backup in football uh
i would just be interested to see how
that whole dynamic worked out as well
yeah they've already paid eli manning
five million they could in theory cut
him there's no trade clause in the
contract but i look you hit on the big
impediment because it's one thing to
make the trade yeah that's another thing
to make the player happy look at what
the bears had to do last year everything
they gave up to get khalil mack and they
still paid him 23.5 million per year and
from wilson's perspective
do you want to be traded right because
if you get traded you don't get market
value if you get traded that's gonna if
they give up two first round picks to
get you that's less money they're gonna
have in mind to pay you it's it's a
combination how much do we have to give
up to get him how much do we have to pay
him and the less you have to give up to
get him the more you're willing to pay
him and i think for wilson the better
play is if he decides he wants to go to
another team go year to year under this
the franchise tag until the seahawks say
we're just not going to apply the
franchise tag again and that may come as
soon as 2021 when it would be 36.4
million for one season so i i don't know
that that's the right outcome for wilson
unless you find a team that is willing
to part with significant draft pick
compensation and
make him at least a 34 million dollar a
year player on his next contract yeah no
i i get that all those things have to be
taken into account uh as far as if you
want to get russell wilson and whatever
that might be i mean hey this is big
time conversation where happened we're
talking about one of the best
quarterbacks in football on a premier
franchise really franchises have been
extremely relevant one of the best
organizations in football
over the last seven eight years and
they're talking about or we're hearing
rumors uh about maybe russell wilson not
being on their team i mean this would be
one of the biggest trades in the history
of football i find it unlikely to happen
between now and the draft uh i i mean
and again john carr i mean john
schneider and pete carroll seem like two
that would have guts to make these type
of moves but man uh i don't think it's
going to i don't think it's gonna happen
this year i guess is what i'm saying i
could see something happen at the end of
this season but it's still nonetheless
very interesting that jack del rio would
go on tv and say something like that
let's do kind of a speed round here with
teams that that would be potentially
interested in him right now
this year if he's available i still
think it's more realistic for something
that would be discussing in 2020 but
let's say the seahawks are motivated to
just get out of this mess now okay this
financial mess and move on dolphins
should the dolphins make a play for it
oh that would be a i mean yes
yes they could make a play certainly
have a great need that would change
around their roster their outlook on
their team all together everything would
be positive certainly go ahead
cincinnati bengals they would never pay
him but that's a team that look andy
dalton they're uncertain and they they
want to take advantage of the final year
of dalton's contract to see if he can do
the zack taylor offense i mean the
bengals are the one team i look at in
the afc north and say there there should
be interest but
i'm answering my own question here
they're never going to pay him so never
sierra is not going to cincinnati i mean
that's just not happening there's no way
i just don't see that happening so that
would be shocking to me
well and you know if if we assume that
that his wife's geographic preferences
are going to be a major factor here
that's going to knock out a lot of these
teams that potentially would be
interested i i think the top team right
is either the giants or the la chargers
hey now what are you gonna do with
philip rivers right but but i i i think
that it makes sense and that's why i say
next year would make even more sense
because it would be easier for the
chargers to make the switcheroo if they
choose to do it
move on from philip rivers and at the
same time bring in russell wilson but
there aren't a lot of obvious
destinations if the trade were to happen
now i think it's something that we need
to be watching for 2020. i just think
it's going to be a hard
up challenge for a team to come up with
what the seahawks would want and
to give russell wilson what he would
want yeah no i agree i look at it as a
2020 type move as well and think that
there can be some more spots maybe that
even open up you know whether the
washington redskins what's that
quarterback situation after the year uh
you mentioned the chargers i think
that's a very good thought hey the
oakland raiders we'll see how that goes
this year with derek carr and company
they might be wanting a new quarterback
who the hell knows what goes on there
but nonetheless what you said mike i
mean you mentioned two teams and even
though it seems far-fetched to us the
giants and the chargers
those are two teams that have also been
linked to josh rosen trades as well so
they're obviously thinking about
quarterback moves i have no idea whether
they've contacted russell wilson of the
seattle seahawks or had any conversation
about that but we know those two teams
are at least dabbling in the quarterback
market and thinking about future moves
would you trade if you were the
cardinals the number one overall pick
for russell wilson oh gosh
uh no i would not because i would just
go i'm getting the new age russell
wilson uh without having to trade
anything away for him and kyle or murray
so i would not notify but how do you
know but you don't know how he's gonna
make it i know but i you know again i
look at it and it's we don't know we
don't know anything you're exactly right
but you gotta trust your evaluation and
a guy like cliff kingsbury who's seen
them forever and said nothing but
positive things and then you got a lot
of other issues with your team let alone
the rookie salary cap thing we've talked
about to add into that if i was the
cardinals as awesome as i think russell
wilson is i would go nope we'll get the
new age kyler murray and try to make him
the the next russell wilson
yeah you're gonna pay kyle murray over
four years less than you're going to pay
russell wilson in one year right much
less than what you're going to pay
russell wilson in one year but you know
if you think of it in terms of
well you know every time you use that
draft pick you are trading that pick for
a player and and if russell wilson were
in the draft pool right now with his
financial requirements attached to him
where would he go right if if you if you
could draft russell wilson right now at
age 30
with the salary he's going to want
what would his floor be let's say the
cardinals wouldn't take him at one
they'd go with the cheaper and maybe
every bit as good kyler murray but but
where where how how long does he linger
in the green room in nashville if he's
available at age 30 at his current
salary expectation knowing you're gonna
have to pay him 34 million a year or
more i don't know i don't know yeah i
don't know i would think he would really
link he wouldn't linger along i would
think i really wouldn't i would think
kyler murray would go off the board and
then it would be russell wilson next
even with the 30 year old age next to
him and the contract demands because i
think there's questions about all these
quarterbacks that are in the first round
to a degree to where nobody feels
totally a hundred percent warm and cozy
oh this guy is a slam dunk you know
superstar i don't get the feeling like
you got that with last year with certain
teams beliefs in baker mayfield or josh
allen or sam darnold i don't think
that's going on the same way this year
with drew locke dwayne haskins and
daniel jones
if i was the giants without question i
would pick up the phone and i would call
pete carroll and or john schneider and
say let's try to work something out
without question and i'd give up maybe
six this year in the first round pick
next year although the first round pick
next year could be higher than 17 this
year i would give two first round picks
for russell wilson and i would pay him
because uh that would immediately
restore the credibility of that
franchise and allow the giants to to
build around russell wilson into the
future and uh and maybe get to the
playoffs more than once every seven
years yeah i think that's if he's gonna
be traded this year that's the one team
that's the one team you think it'll be
the giants that make them make a move or
do it yeah again i don't think so i
think they're still gonna go all in with
eli manning for one year but i do think
the giants are going to make a move for
a quarterback so you know i just think
it'll be the draft though i think that
the new york giants are going to take a
quarterback in the draft uh but that
does make sense i mean with russell
wilson and the new york giants i hear he
will change around the organization in a
hurry
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports